what percent of ruined women really know
how to have family traditions what
percent of women really value the family
what percent of women really aren't out
every week let us know because that is
the foundation is a woman makes a house
into a home and that's not that's why
they say when you look at a society and
see how it's doing you look at the women
and the women today they're overweight
they've slept with more people and and
we're less successful in relationships
we're the ones the way Society has gone
they've made it more accepted for women
to be by themselves half the kids and
not have the money involved why haven't
they given men a lot of incentive to
stay at home because all right a woman
can be high on this and high
statistically and that but really
untruly the man it's all down to him in
a way he will make the proposal he would
choose his wife and all of that so why
has not the system give more incentive
for the men to stay okay I can tell you
why actually so when um the system
[Music]
no it's it's the women it's the women's
choices so because women leave 70 to 80
percent of the time 90 of their college
educated so the women are the ones
ruining the relationships who ruins the
relationship the one that stays the one
that leaves the quitter ruins it cannot
just say the women have more incentive
to be by themselves correct and why is
that because they financially ruin men
in order to financially the system wants
to tax everybody
no no no I'll tell you I'll tell you why
because I'm actually researching if you
want to I'm actually I'll tell you I'll
tell you why if you want to know because
I'm actually researching this the issue
is that the the politicians have no
incentive to change the laws because the
biggest group of Swing voters is women
and single mothers are the biggest
voters so why would they take away the
benefits of single mothers even if men
are committing suicide every single day
because of these policies
now some could argue that women
shouldn't vote
women got to vote but yeah can you see
where I'm coming from like the
incentives are crazy now let me tell you
something this is where I'm coming
options are crazy but we don't have to
take them women don't have to take those
which I haven't yeah I'm not talking
about you no but I'm one person that
hasn't I'm the woman that hasn't you
know but let me tell you something let
me tell you something I had my best
friend from school right and I don't
even want to break down their parents
right now I love you I love you all but
my best friend from school free kids no
husband no actually she had a fiance she
committed suicide like why would my best
friend from school do that now that's
where I'm coming from and that's why I
had to escape that because look where my
best friend is today
you know you had to escape what I had to
escape that environment that environment
yeah I'll be in a bit toxic a bit
generational curved so she killed she
killed herself because I did I don't
know maybe because I don't know why I
don't know why we don't know why but she
you know she left her family her
everybody was so close and you know
even though these women are saying that
they're gonna leave they're gonna do
this they're still not happy in in
making that choice but then the men
still don't have no incentive to come
back or to stay or to make it work with
the women that then they bear children
with you know but that's that's just
that narrative just isn't true it's just
wrong because because the men are not
leaving the women are leaving women
with two kids right okay but that's the
exception it's not the rule
I'm saying okay out of 10 marriages if
there's 10 marriages two are the men
leaving eight are the women leaving so
who's the problem
all right Believers maybe the easy
answer Believers leave us which is the
women but it's the incentives that they
have they probably be like oh I've got
too much um I don't know
but this is but this is the thing this
is why I say modern women are selfish
because it's me me before the family oh
even if they have the incentives like a
true traditional woman would never take
them but she doesn't care because she
cares about the kids first maybe they're
coming from a place where they've seen
that okay the traditional woman has been
unhappy for the most of her life been
unhappy that's statistics
but that's that's not true that's not
true it's true either women when
families are happier than women without
families 80 of women that are single and
childless are not happy that they're
that way
the single most unhappiest demographic
there's lots of data on This is 40 year
old single unmarried women the single
most unhappiest demographic
I'm not saying everybody is like
statistics you know don't apply to
individuals but that's just like data
it's just and it's just right definitely
and it's like why do we I feel like
Hollywood Hollywood
has brainwashed us into thinking that
traditional women were not happy because
there were unhappy times you know I I
know a couple and I've told the story a
couple times this couple they were they
were together and the woman
um the man actually left the house for
for a side chick so he left he left the
house completely left her and this woman
was so Catholic that she prayed she
prayed to God for a solution she said
God please God like I send my husband
home I just want to work it out side
chick died
side chick she died
and and he came home and they stayed
married for 50 years that sounds like
murder Pearl no no no no no no
I promise they lived I promise I promise
no murder no murder but but that's what
I mean and and she wasn't spiteful she
didn't hold it over his head she she
looked at herself and said what how did
I contribute to this and how can we
solve it but women women like that don't
exist anymore that doesn't exist
yeah like women that really believed the
families before me but why why are the
women but you got to ask yourself these
questions why are the women turning back
on their men why because they're selfish
apart from being selfish I need more
than selfishness because because I mean
some of the number like some of the top
indicators of divorce are um uh
Financial
um cheating
um what are the other ones it's like
Financial cheating and
irreconcilable differences yeah that's
like the top three times are married 85
Google it 85 percent of millionaires are
married no that's good because that
means that they have a strong woman
behind them oh is that what it means
everything
we take way too much credit I'll give
you an example now Melinda Melinda Gates
him Bill Gates okay Melinda Gates and
Bill Gates was Bill Gates suddenly lost
and not so now don't get me wrong I'm
not saying that the women have no part
to play what happened the successful men
are going to be successful regardless
when when Melinda or let's take um the
Bezos Jeff Bezos and whatever
whatever like he got richer she got
poorer was she that important
when it comes to his success was he not
going to be successful when raising the
kids having him as a family that's
that's the point like what behind every
successful man is not always a
successful woman it's a supportive woman
if the statistics are 85 of millions out
there you know of a millionaires they're
married right that means that they're
truly happy they're happy to make money
they're happy to go home they're happy
to be with their wives and happiness and
they're not marrying you
that should be a concern no it's not
about me because you're statistics
you're saying here
a successful
I chose not to be okay I chose not to be
we have choices like she says women are
always breaking up behind maybe it was
me I walked away I did do you think do
you think that you have no room for
improvement there's no no room there's
room there's a lot so you've got to do
it with the right so so why why is that
your answer so because it's like if
someone says to me millionaires aren't
trying to marry you I would be like okay
well
it's 85 I don't know why you have to
break it though
listen okay it's the question is how can
I improve to get there if you're not
where you want to be how can you improve
to get there but you have to admit
there's a problem by taking the steps
and if you're being distracted by men
that you know they're not going to be
supportive on your journey okay it's
gonna be a fecal Journey if you had a
partner and you turned around I mean no
can I just say if you had a partner and
you turn around to him and say I'm gonna
I'm gonna quit my job and I'm gonna be a
tick tocker it's gonna look at you but
what though really he ain't gonna even
see your vision or your gold would you
want your message
I didn't I had I I didn't have a
boyfriend then but honestly when I told
my dad he supported me
no but this is this is it's just because
it should but just because this is and
not many men listen oh my gosh listen
listen just because that's the men you
pick that's the men you deal with i i
that's that's the men that you pick and
the all men are not like that wow most
men that I that I've dated and extremely
supportive I'm always fair I must admit
the man who has been truly supportive
I'm just not attracted to him obviously
can't obviously
that is my personal life choice why is
it so wrong for me it's not that choice
it's not it's not wrong but it's like
anytime anyone says anything to you it's
like you're arguing I just know but I
have you know I'm I'm probably coming
from a place where I'm talking from a
woman who's probably coming from the um
another different background and it
hasn't been so privileged I mean so many
people I talk to oh my god dude I talked
to I've talked to hundreds I can't
imagine I've talked to hundreds and and
I'm telling you you sound
it he said it sounds delusional like the
way you talk just sounds so good it's
not it is
in order to quit your job and be a tick
Tucker you've got to be here
but this is the thing I have outcomes
yes outcomes and and when and when and
when I figured out I wasn't getting the
outlet listen listen and when you figure
out you're not getting the outcome you
want you have to change something
and there were times where I was not
getting the outcome I wanted and I had
to change something but when you it's
like there's no you actually there's no
room for improvement ever what do you
mean based that based on the way you've
you've conducted yourself in this
conversation and you you can take it or
leave it it's your life it's not room
for improvement I don't get that part
can I um I have a really funny this is a
Jerry Seinfeld joke and it's like it's
been called I think it's Jerry Seinfeld
and I want to give the right credit he
said the funniest thing ever is that
when you see two homeless people talking
to each other one is giving the other
advice oh bless let's just think about
that again yes I want to say it again
when you see two homework when you see
two homeless people talking to each
other one is giving the other advice
well yeah so the point that right so
that's really kind of funny it's like
what's he tell yeah do this oh okay like
it's like it's so absurdly funny yeah
yeah one of the things I teach the young
fellows and gals in our company I say
this really with no irony I say never
take advice from somebody with whom you
wouldn't trade lives with so guys if
you're watching this right now Pearl you
have a like awesome audience they're
they're trying to decipher what's true
what's not true because they're getting
different messages right look at the
person that you would love their life
and follow their advice and then look at
the person that you would not want their
life and do the opposite and that's
that's probably the the core of what
people want to get at
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible